through anger and grief
and rage what we're talking about is
called mindfulness meditation and people
who do it believe that it makes their
brains healthier and fitter we're about
to cross the threshold into a new world
a buddhist monk who's been called the
happiest man in the world
if you ever wanted a complete scientific
road map for how to live a modern
philosophy to go by a lens through which
to understand a complicated world a
foundation for life well the 17th
century dutch philosopher baruch
despinoza is as good as you'll find
today you'll learn how to see yourself
as something bigger something infinite
and awe inspiring how to see the world
scientifically too
what this means for reducing negative
emotions leading a more content
fulfilled and rational and meaningful
and joyful life
he asked questions like
why are we so dogmatic
what makes us so irrational
why do we live as slaves to our emotions
and other people's opinions we'll find
out why some of the most influential
thinkers to have ever lived admired
spinoza so much einstein said if he
believed in god it was spinoza's god and
hegel said that you are either
espionosis or not a philosopher at all
we'll look at what made spinoza one of
the first truly modern and radical
thinkers
why he was the first modern psychologist
and how he revolutionized how we think
about concepts like god
and nature
in short
and i think this is no exaggeration
the world we inhabit today
would not be the same would not have
taken the path it has
without baruch spinoza
this is also the story of a man
lost in the forest searching for a way
out
statues portraits even streets bear his
name he has become an icon of
reason and not the solitary thinker
i don't want to dwell too much on
spinoza's life except to say that he has
a good claim on being one of the most
consequential philosophers to have ever
lived but he was also as bertrand
russell wrote the noblest and most
lovable of the great philosophers
he was one of the first enlightenment
advocates for real democracy and was the
first to really criticize the bible as
just a text he was vilified for his
perceived atheism and excommunicated
from the jewish community where he lived
he said that the lord will not spare him
the anger and wrath of the lord will
rage against this man and bring upon him
all the curses however despite being
ostracized from everyone he searched his
entire life for what he called the true
good
[Music]
he wanted to find out how to live an
ideal and virtuous life
how
ultimately to be free
before we get to the juicy bits we have
to do the grunt work we have to map out
spinoza's idea of the universe
then
we can understand our place in it
it might sound a little bit complicated
at first but bear with me if you get
this
or at least just let it wash over you
and stick with it
it will change how you think
give me a few minutes to get through the
complicated bits and then we'll get to
the interesting stuff and it should all
come together
if you could condense spinoza's
metaphysics his first principles into
one sentence it would be this
being
is one
put another way the many
what that means is actually quite simple
everything
us the forest
animals plants
stars the laws of physics and many
things that are part of one thing
nature
we forget this of course we think of
ourselves as independent as separate
but we also know that we're not and we
know this even more in the modern period
we know that we're made of atoms we know
that we need food water oxygen energy
from outside of us to sustain those
atoms we know that we rely on wood and
tools and gravity and of course each
other we know about the circle of life
the interdependent ecosystem that the
animal kingdom and the plant kingdom
lives within and we know that one thing
affects another
in short we know that everything is
connected
so how does he understand this many
things in one nature truth well he wants
to lay it out logically and represent it
in a kind of geometrical mathematical
pattern so that we can use it to build
more complex ideas with so instead of
just saying many things and one nature
he says that there are three parts to
the universe
substance attributes and modes
we usually think of substances as the
different things in the universe
air
us
wood
deer
dirt for example
it's just the stuff that things are made
out of
attributes on the other hand are the way
we experience those substances
spinoza says there are two that we know
of
extension
and thought
we have actual material trees
and then the idea of trees in our heads
a mode is the form or shape the
substance takes the substance would for
example could be in the mode of a tree
or a chair or a door
it's the substance of wood in different
forms shapes
modes
but wait spinoza wants to be more
specific
a substance he says
if it's to be defined properly should be
an independent thing he provides
definitions
by substance i understand what is in
itself and is conceived through itself
i.e that whose concept doesn't have to
be formed out of the concept of
something else
so
let's take
a leaf
is it a substance well it's only a
substance if it's in itself if it's
independent if it's conceived through
itself if it doesn't have to be formed
out of something else
but of course
it does
it's dependent on the branch and the
tree
so is the tree a substance well no
because it's formed out of the soil the
air and the birds that disperse its
seeds
a substance should be an independent
thing yet thinking through this thought
experiment everything is in some sense
determined dependent an extension of
things outside of it
so if we're defining substances strictly
it turns out there's only one
nature
trees people plants animals there we're
all different modes different shapes of
nature
of mata
spinoza saw nature as god in fact he
usually wrote god
or nature
they're one and the same thing
why is this well he thought of it like
this
god is meant to be this infinite
all-powerful omnipresent omniscient law
maker and law giver but if that's the
case he can't be outside of nature if
he's not just part of nature if he's not
everywhere at once he can't be
omnipresent he can't be infinite he must
to be those things be part of everything
with nothing inseparable from him or her
or it
god couldn't be outside the universe
spinoza realized he was
the universe
the ultimate laws were gravity
mathematics the laws of physics of cause
and effect so god knowing all
seeing all controlling all had to not
just be part of those laws but actually
be those laws as if they were an
extension of
itself
today this is called pantheism
spinoza was writing at the beginning of
the enlightenment and during the
scientific revolution he was trying in
some way to square an old universe with
a new one one of science of reason of
experimentation
he saw that all things if you studied
them carefully enough were implicated
and affected by everything else
everything was clearly part of one big
ordered ecosystem although he didn't
have that word ecosystem to use yet it
was a revolutionary
modern scientific view
spinazer writes in nature there is
nothing contingent all things have been
caused by the necessity of the divine
nature to exist and produce an effect in
a certain way
a storm pushes me one way the wind
pushes my boat
berries draw me towards eating them
the tree grows depending on the rain and
the sun
the deer is frightened in a different
direction when startled we all have
desires we can't control
we are all like billiard balls set off
by causes outside of us spinoza's
universe is a description of a singular
timeless fact
everything is connected
being is one to understand ourselves we
must understand the natural world we are
a part of
you know when you come right down to it
there are only two views we can take
either this all happened by accident or
it's the result of design and plan
you might just shrug your shoulders and
say well it's just a matter of personal
opinion and let it go with that
you might that is but for the fact that
this is an issue which vitally affects
your whole life
it's going to determine how you think
and how you live
there's a phrase that comes up often in
scholars discussions about spinoza's
universe
it unfolds
cause and effect causing effect cause an
effect
this is the root of everything
a seed unfolds into a tree a pang of
hunger unfolds into the making of a mill
the desire for sex unfolds into a new
human life this path unfolds through the
woods and the cloud unfolds into the sky
the universe
since the big bang has unfolded into an
infinity of different shapes and modes
i shall consider human actions and
appetites as if it were a question of
lines planes and bodies
[Music]
what does this mean
that we can conceptualize trace and map
lines through our appetites actions and
ideas they're caused by something before
them and they in turn were caused by
something before that and the effects of
those causes go on into the future
spinoza writes the infant thinks that he
freely wants the milk the angry child
that he freely wants vengeance and the
timid one that he freely wants to flee
the drunkard thinks it is from a free
decision of the mind that he says things
which when he sobers up he regrets
having said
this forces us to confront her
frightening proposition
are we free at all
spinoza says that all the evidence
points to know
in the mind there is no absolute or free
will but the mind is determined to will
this or that by a cause which is also
determined by another and this again by
another and so too infinity we only
think we're free because our
consciousness sits between one of those
causes and effect between for example
the pang of hunger and the decision to
eat but we see the effect of something
like hunger or desire and then see that
effect as a volition a choice a
voluntary action
let me explain
i just heard a lion over there in the
english countryside
so i decide to go this way
am i choosing freely when moving my leg
this way was caused by the effect of the
lion's roar
everything is cause and effect however
we rarely reflect on the long line of
causation that came before all action is
caused by something external
just because we watch over our own
appetites ideas and actions as they
enter and leave our minds we think that
we're free
the french philosopher jill's delus
wrote that consciousness is only a dream
with one's eyes open
consciousness in other words is being
sat over the top of the waterfall
watching mental stuff fly over it
spinoza writes a body in motion moves
until another body causes it to rest and
a body at rest remains at rest until
another body causes it to move
now
here's the interesting bit
how things modes objects us ideas
whatever it is are affected by other
things depends on the natures of each
thing the bird affects the tree in a
different way than the rain does
an idea or a sentence affects two
different people in two different ways
everything affects everything else in
some specific way what's the
scientifically minded approach to this
to understand how things affect other
things that's the key to the universe
it is clear that we are driven about in
many ways by external causes and that
like waves on the sea driven by contrary
winds we toss about not knowing our
outcome and fate
he says that we have inadequate ideas
about the effects of things the trick to
life of course is to have
adequate ideas
the way we make decisions in our
democratic system has a profound effect
on our welfare and happiness
whether we're dealing with a personal
problem or a business matter
whether we are deciding on our schools
our taxes or any other community problem
the first thing we have to do is get the
facts
okay imagine for one moment those lines
of cause and effect running through the
universe delus calls those lines the
plane of imminence the bird is something
to the tree the tree to the soil the
soil to the worm and so on
the lion to the person running
there is a line that can be drawn from
my first videos to the writing of this
one to me being in this forest and that
line continues into the future
when we think in terms of lines we
realize that everything in the universe
is relative to something else all is a
web
this again has radical consequences that
should change how we think it means that
nothing is good or bad in itself but
only relative to something else the lion
is bad for me so i run from it
the berry
is good for me so i'm drawn to it
we tend to think of things as good or
bad beautiful or ugly true or not true
we attach properties to objects and
think of them as being certain things
this is red it's tasty or it's poisonous
or that person is cheerful
intelligent or interesting or that
argument is a good or bad idea
but we forget that it's always us that's
attaching the property
the goodness or badness the ugly or
beautiful the wise or unwise so that
these appraisals of objects ideas or
people aren't actually properties that
are in the thing itself but are
descriptions of a relationship
everything is relative
and the consequences of thinking like
this get even more radical
if things can't be defined by properties
in themselves but only by relations
between things then they must be
understood only in their capacities to
do things to other things or the
capacity to have things done to them by
other things this is what spinoza calls
simply their capacity to affect and be
affected
oh look a giraffe
in the english countryside
why does it have a long neck
the reason is not within the giraffe
itself
a property of the giraffe but in its
relationship to eating from trees or
drinking water or fighting with other
giraffes
this applies to everything
delus writes that beings will be defined
by their capacity for being affected by
the affections of which they are capable
the excitations to which they react
those by which they are unaffected and
those which exceed their capacity and
make them ill or cause them to die
okay now things are getting interesting
if everything is about relationships
capacities to affect or to be affected
cause an effect then how should we think
about our relationship to the things
around us what do we want to surround
ourselves with
what do we want to avoid
the answer is quite simple we should
want to surround ourselves with
perfection we should try and organize
our experience of the world so that we
encounter things that will affect us
positively
the things we call good the things that
our relationship with affect us
positively we of course like we approve
of we want more of
a good shelter has the effect of
sheltering us from the rain great start
this is why spinoza sees goodness and
perfection as synonymous
but more than this he says that by
perfection and goodness he just means
existing
what does this mean
well a house that exists for a longer
period is more perfect than the one
destroyed in a storm a person that lives
longer has a body that's more perfect
than one that dies from a disease a
plant that gives us more energy is more
perfect to us than one that doesn't
god or nature is more perfect because it
exists for a longer period of time than
an individual tree or a single animal
things generally want to exist for as
long as possible so whatever helps that
thing achieve that is more perfect in
its relationship with it than something
that doesn't spinoza says simply
whatever helps us attain that perfection
we shall call good and whatever hinders
are attaining it or does not assist it
we shall call evil
and we try to arrange our ideas of the
world in this way as well in such a way
as to achieve this perfection
he says after men began to form
universal ideas and devise models of
houses buildings towers etc
and to prefer some models of things to
others
it came about that each one called
perfect what he saw agreed with the
universal idea he had formed of this
kind of thing
i think of fire in connection with
emotions because when you become stirred
up
when your emotions control your actions
it affects not only yourself but the
people around you
psychologists find that control of
emotions can be gained by understanding
the stimulus response pattern
okay so lines of cause and effect run
through everything and everything has
different capacities to be affected by
and affect other things
let's think about those affections
look a gorilla
in the english countryside
i hear the gorilla i see the gorilla i
feel fear the gorilla's capacity to beat
me in an arm wrestle affects me and i'm
pushed i'm affected
into running
spinoza says that
unpleasure is a man's passing from a
greater perfection to a lesser
now again this applies to everything our
sad angry fearful hungry annoyed
stressed anxious frustrated feelings
about things are signals that something
is affecting us in a negative way that
we're passing into a lesser state of
perfection
think about hunger you're literally
decomposing so the hunger pushes you to
eat for sustenance
stress is based on the fear that i don't
know if you don't finish this task
you'll be judged poorly by others and it
will hurt your career on the other hand
he says pleasure is a man's passing from
a lesser perfection to a greater
like the term unfolding for the universe
and lines for cause and effect our
emotions and feelings are signals of the
potential passage to a better or worse
condition a reaction to objects we
encounter in the world
spinoza calls feelings emotions and
passions the affects because they affect
us he thinks that all affects boil down
to three main ones from which all the
others derive joy
sadness and desire
and they're all related to spinoza's
idea of perfection
joy is the experience of our condition
being improved sadness our condition
worsening anger fear hunger feeling cold
are all sad effects sad passions he
calls them whereas love or confidence
are examples of the joyful effects but
remember
everything is relative the effects are
always about something in that line of
cause and effect so he says that a full
account of the nature of each passion
must bring in the nature of the external
object by which the person having the
passion is affected
again it's the relationship we have to
focus on we try to organize our lives
rationally around how often we'll
encounter use or avoid certain things we
want the shelter for more warmth and
less rain we want the good ideas about
raising our children or choosing new
hobbies we want to avoid the things that
make us sick
so how does this relate to spinoza's big
idea the thing he spent his entire life
trying to discover finding what he
called the true good of being free
the next step is to consider different
opinions based on the facts
and the final step is to weigh the facts
and opinions with understanding and
objectivity these standards apply to
everyone
whether it's a family planning where to
take a vacation
or a group of students discussing a
school project
or a women's club planning a charity
drive or a city council debating a
community problem
all of them have to have the facts
before they are able to reach
intelligent decisions
okay so we're affected by things we want
to be affected by good things we want to
become more perfect in spinoza's words
everything's a relationship too
how do we begin to bring all of this
together
first spinoza is an ethical egoist that
means that essentially what is good and
bad for us individually guides us in
what we do how we think and act he said
that reason demands that everyone love
himself seek his own advantage and
absolutely that everyone should strive
to preserve his own being as far as he
can
he called this an organism's
which he defines in various ways at
various times as an organism's striving
endeavor
tendency force and power of acting it
applies to the tree as much as it does
to us
every organism strives to increase its
connotus to exist for longer to achieve
a better state of perfection he says
simply that each thing as far as it can
by its own power tries to stay in
existence
because of our connotus we have a desire
for things that increase our well-being
food sex love shelter good ideas and an
aversion to those things that decrease
it poison violence lions gorillas
but how does our connotus guide us in
doing this
what are we doing
of course we have those natural urges
and some things are of course better for
us and others not
but as usual with spinoza he takes the
insights one step further
in knowing that the lion is bad for us
and the berry good
we're doing something else too
we're understanding those lines the
affections the causes and effects in the
world
the connotus needs to understand to
comprehend so as to increase its power
of doing the right thing to live longer
this is why spinoza is a rationalist
understanding is the key to everything
understanding is the key to freedom
how can spinoza argue that we're all
pushed around by affections out of our
control and argue that we can be free
remember he says it's clear that we are
driven about in many ways by external
causes and that like waves on the sea
driven by contrary winds we toss about
not knowing our outcome and fate
it's that tossing about that he wants to
address
the affects passions and emotions are
passive they happen to us
like the wind hitting a sail a wave
crashing over a ship i see cake and my
mouth salivates and i eat it i feel like
an idea is a good one so i do it i think
the sound is bad so i run
but often our ideas are mistaken about
whether those effects are really helping
us
what we want to do is understand the
real causes and effects of what we do we
want to know what really caused that
sound in the woods before we run if it's
really harmful and where we're going if
that cake is really what i want to
improve my condition if that idea is
really accurate
spinoza says that just relying on
feelings and affects is basically a
state of slavery because we're pushed
around by them not understanding and
choosing for ourselves
instead of being passive we want to be
active the difference between a man who
is led only by an affect or by opinion
and one who is led by reason for the
former whether he will or no does those
things he is most ignorant of whereas
the latter complies with no one's wishes
but his own
and only does those things he knows to
be the most important in life and
therefore desires vary greatly hence i
call the former a slave but the latter a
free man
okay so what does being active actually
entail
someone who is active is guided by their
connotus their desire for longevity for
joy and perfection and they should be
what spinoza calls the adequate or
sufficient cause of what they're doing
to do this we use our reason
to study the causes and effects of those
relationships between things around us
we want to understand those effects on
us and the effect they might have in
turn on things in the future
adequate ideas are clear and distinct
knowledge about what increases a
person's connedus because a person has
studied the causes and effects of things
around them
okay an example
inadequate knowledge is eating because
you desire to because you're hungry
it might have a good effect it might not
this berry might actually poison me
adequate knowledge however is eating in
a rational way
knowing the nutrients where it grows
what goes into it and the effect it has
on you in the long term how much it
contributes to your health all the
factors all the causes and effects
that's why i have my foraging guide
i don't know why i'm throwing my
cowberry away
i wonder is that actually a cayberry
cabery can you see
description also known as the
lingamberry this is a small evergreen
cadburys are acidic but can be eaten raw
they're best used to make an excellent
jelly commonly added to jams pies and
fruit sweets
spinoza writes that when a rational
being is truly active and so far as he
is moved by the knowledge he possesses
the things he does are guided by a true
understanding of what is in his own best
interest and thus bring about an
improvement in his condition
in other words the free active
reasonable person is driven by
self-determination being active and
reasonable requires thinking through the
causes and effects of things
sufficiently enough to be able to
overcome our simple passions and
emotions
in knowing that i'm hungry
or that i can store them
and that the berry contributes to my
vitamin c intake i've done the research
i know how much i need i know where to
find them and then i'm acting picking
eating storing in an active way not a
passive way
an adequate idea of what to do takes
into account all the factors and if we
do this he says
reason will overcome the weaker impulses
or misguided ideas
deluse writes that once we have attained
adequate ideas we connect effects to
their true causes and consciousness
having become a reflection of adequate
ideas is capable of overcoming its
illusions forming clear and distinct
ideas of the affections and effects it
experiences
spinoza scholar stephen nadler gives the
example of the choice between staying at
home and studying or going out partying
with friends
in the moment going out might have a
stronger effect on your desire but if we
consider all the factors about our
finances or the job we might get from
the effect of staying in studying we
might come to the conclusion that it's
more rational to stay in and study
alternatively we might still decide we
need a night off because we're
overworked
spinoza is not saying that one thing is
better than the other
only that we have to consider our
options we have to really understand the
effects of our choices we have to
use our heads
nadler writes that a person is therefore
free when his adequate ideas are more
powerful effectively speaking than his
passions or inadequate ideas for spinoza
freedom is about reason and someone who
is free is someone who acts according to
the dictate of reason
he says that the only thing that reason
makes us try to get is understanding
we're going to explore several different
realms of god's creation
before we're finished i think you'll
agree that our god is a wonderful god
spinoza spends a lot of time in the
ethics commenting on virtue vice emotion
and feeling and trying to understand
their relationship to reason
he is a rationalist after all he wants
to make the case that using our reason
will direct us without error along the
correct path
advice for example is an immoderate love
or desire for eating drinking sexual
union wealth and esteem
this might bring pleasure in the short
term but they're harmful over a longer
period
fortitude for spinoza is a virtue above
all others he says
from the guidance of reason we want a
greater future good and preference to a
lesser present one and a lesser present
evil in preference to a greater future
one
fortitude is the act of working hard
looking forward thinking broadly
investing our time in understanding how
the world works so that we can reap
future rewards
but here's the beautiful bit
everything in spinoza connects in some
way
remember how fuspinosa god is
nature god is in
everything god is perfect because nature
just is
it's that unfolding line of cause and
effect that runs through everything
it's the fact that the many
a one
all is one
substance well
he says to overcome acting passively and
to choose the rational thing to live
with fortitude we must
look to god to nature to see what lasts
what works what's most perfect and most
beautiful to increase our own connotus
as a species in a relationship with the
rest of nature
he wants to look from what he describes
as the perspective of eternity
god offers to create in us a new life
a life of peace instead of turmoil
a life of victory instead of sin and
defeat
the life of eternal glory instead of
eternal suffering
and he's great enough to do the job
it will only let him
[Music]
think about how people give up smoking
when they have kids or maybe get more
humble and tolerant from traveling the
world the wider the view the more
long-term orientated you become the more
things you consider you look at causes
over the perspective of a longer period
of time across a broader space
[Music]
looking to eternity is the most godly
way of thinking looking at everything
from a god's eye view from the
perspective of eternity and what causes
things what affects things over the long
term
he says perfecting the intellect is
nothing but understanding god his
attributes and his actions which follow
from the necessity of his nature
to take one more example think about
growing a plant to eat we learn from god
from nature by watching by experiencing
by seeing what happens when it rains
what soil it grows best in which
nutrients and how much sunlight it needs
or in building a high say we look for
the strongest wood that's the best
insulator and lasts the longest is the
most eco-friendly spinoza says simply
that everything in life works in the
same way
uh uses young petals have a fragrant
aroma
true
and are worth harvesting and use if you
have the patience once enough petals
have been gathered use them to make a
light panna cotta swirl them into a
sweet cake or infuse them with a little
chili in home brewed mead
he says
he who understands himself and his
affects clearly and distinctly loves god
and does so the more the more he
understands himself and his affects
[Music]
spinoza says a few things about the free
person's character and talks at length
about different virtues emotions and
vices but fundamentally the person led
by reason and guided by understanding
nature will have two things
strength of character that's the
fortitude the striving the will to
understand the world and they'll be
active choosing by reason not passive
pushed around by the affections
[Music]
spinoza was influenced by the stoics of
ancient greece and rome instead of
relying on capricious and unpredictable
joys like sensual pleasure and fears or
anger ultimate freedom he says is
grounded in reason
and from this comes a joyful serenity
that arises from the knowledge that
doing the rational correct thing should
pay off in the end
joy remember is the feeling of an
increase in our connotus an increase in
power so spinoza's ethics is grounded in
increasing and active in controlled
rational joy
but because we're part of the universe
we'll also take joy in seeing the
affections and relationships of the
world for what they are
being
integral to it a thing within it
he says a person who sees the necessity
of things regards their passage with
calm and composure
getting frustrated and angry at the
universe is the result of seeing the
world through the lens of inadequate
ideas
imagine getting angry with the lion
blaming the lion for wanting to eat you
you know it's not the lion's choice not
her fault she's not morally responsible
spinoza just says that we should look at
the rest of the world in this way too
seeing from the perspective of eternity
means looking at how different
affections different causes and effects
affect things with different levels of
power so the power of the lion biting
your leg has its cause in the lion's
hunger we don't get angry upset or
frustrated with the lion personally now
imagine asking someone for directions in
the street and the person ignores us we
get a little frustrated but then we
discover that the person speaks a
different language or is deaf or is
scared of us because they were harassed
on the streets last week there are
causes we didn't consider and have a
powerful effect on the person and when
we look from the perspective of eternity
it becomes difficult for us to direct
our negative emotions at single people
ideas or objects it becomes unreasonable
spinoza says
if we separate an emotion affect from
the thought of an external cause and
join it to the other thoughts then the
love or hate toward the external cause
is destroyed as is the mental
instability arising from these affects
powerfully we should think of all of the
causes of things again giving us a god's
eye view but also lessening the blame or
negative emotion we feel towards one
isolated thing or one isolated person
as stephen nadler writes this view
serves to distribute the causal
responsibility for the effect widely and
dilute its power significantly perhaps
taking away its strength altogether the
intensity of the effect is weakened as
it becomes less focused on one
particular individual and more on a long
sequence of necessitating causes the
same applies to our own negative
emotions our own problems we must have
knowledge about their causes and effects
otherwise we become slaves to them
because ultimately we want to increase
the joyful effects and decrease the
negative ones he says so someone who was
led solely by his love of freedom to
moderate his affects and appetites will
try his hardest to come to know the
virtues and their causes and to fill his
mind with the joy that comes from the
true knowledge of them he will not think
about men's vices or disparage men or
take pleasure from putting up a show of
being a free man
if you observe these carefully they
aren't difficult and regularly put them
into practice you will soon be able to
direct most of your actions according to
the command of reason
if you follow his advice spinoza says
you'll find your way out from the
confusion of the forest of affects
you'll be able to see the wood through
the trees
you'll see the bigger picture the one
from eternity the god's eye view
you'll have
perspective
and spinoza's ethics have been applied
to many areas and have only just
scratched the surface here but it boils
down really to this
reflect on the causes of things
[Music]
but
you might be wondering what has any of
this got to do with morality his most
famous work is called the ethics after
all spinoza's picture of the world seems
to be quite
self-centered so before we end i want to
touch on what spinoza says about
community morality and benevolence
for spinoza morals can only be grounded
in the simple fact that every organism
and being wants to increase their own
spinoza's morality or benevolence is
based on the idea that it's rationally
wise to surround oneself with other
people who are also rational as rational
people he says will want the same things
as one another he says that
there is nothing more useful to a man
than a man
men i repeat can wish for nothing more
helpful to their staying in existence
than that all men
should be in such harmony that the minds
and bodies of them all
would be like one mind and one body that
altogether should try as hard as they
can to stay in existence and that
altogether should seek for themselves
the common advantage of all
the opposite of a joy grounded in
understanding and an increasing connotus
are a life lived under the influence of
the sad passions so it's only logical to
want to minimize negativity we assemble
the world rationally in order to avoid
the sad passions we put the effects of
different things together and create
assemblages of medicines technologies
norms and values entertainment
information family and friends as a
species we have common ideas he says the
body has been affected most forcefully
but what is common to all men
we all want to preserve the things that
are good for our nature and many of
these things are common to us all
and if we're arguing angry suspicious
and fearful rather than joyful calm and
rational we're increasing our sad
passions and that shouldn't be anyone's
foundational goal moreover two heads are
better than one when it comes to tasks
and the rational person should always
want to convince the other to come over
to their calls to be rational too
or take the example of trying to work
out how to grow this
bush this tree these flowers
the more people working on the problem
with the same goal the better it will be
scholars have been critical of spinoza's
view here
people have different goals different
values but
i think his point is that we should come
together positively and ground any
disagreement or debate or competition in
those joyful effects rather than the sad
passions the negative ones
i'm not going to summarize it's
impossible to
i'll leave you with the last few lines
of the ethics the road to these things
that i have pointed out now seems very
hard but it can be found and of course
something that is found so rarely is
bound to be hard
for if salvation were ready to hand and
could be found without great effort how
could it come about that almost everyone
neglects it
but excellence is as difficult
as it is rare
[Music]
thank you so much everyone for watching
this video i really really enjoyed
making this one and a huge thank you to
epoch philosophy for lending their voice
for the spinoza quotes you can check out
their great channel through the link
below uh there's a video on deluz and
spinoza you should watch if you liked
this one so thank you to them
and most of all as always thank you to
my patrons all these incredible people
who let me ramble through the woods and
ramble on about philosophy it's my
favorite thing to do if you'd like to
join them get your name in the credits
and access the discord server and get
scripts then you can do so through the
link below for as little as a dollar
please do that if you can if not hit
like leave a comment for engagement
follow me on twitter all the rest of it
it really helps me out
and i'll see you next time
[Music]